all right joining us now is molly
hemingway fox news contributor and
editor-in-chief of the federalist and
charlie hurt fox news contributor as
well and washington times opinion editor
molly
as we report at the top
with the anger
that
biden's dhs expects that we've already
seen after the leak of that draft row
opinion
that democrats seem to be setting the
stage for
a really dirty and some say potentially
violent midterm election season
thought i think i think that's true and
i think that we've seen that with
democrats for the last few cycles how
they have actually been able to use
street violence as part of their agenda
their campaign agenda and it's pretty
clear that this leak and the response to
it was designed to gin up outrage i
think they were frustrated that even
with texas essentially banning most
abortions after a heartbeat is detected
or you know very for much of the
pregnancy and with everyone knowing that
roe is about to be overturned or
believing that to be the case they were
upset that they weren't getting a huge
amount of outrage from it there's so
much failure in the democrat party that
they're resorting to trying to take that
base the the
the people who really support abortion
and get them outraged just to get some
excitement going for their party but i
don't think it's going to be anywhere
near enough with the economy failing and
so many other things failing in the
country yeah charlie you get the sense
that they're hoping like okay the
republicans went there on the big social
issues now we'll show them
it's a big fizzle so far i mean they
have the activist types out there but i
don't see it connecting at all
yeah and there's a lot of evidence that
they're actually having to pay people to
go out there to protest uh not that this
isn't a an important issue but i think
that the you know most american people
whether wherever you come down on the
issue of abortion you believe that
actually putting the putting these uh
questions in the hands of the of the
electorate of the american people to
pick their representatives to to make
laws that's actually an imminently
sensible way of dealing with an issue
that has divided this country for 50
years exactly because as you point out
every night the the justices ripped the
decision away from the american people
and put it in in the hands of uh nine
unelected rogue justices um but but you
know we're entering a very kind of a
kind of a scary time right now because
you know there's nothing more dangerous
than than dangerous that than desperate
politicians who have enjoyed power and
have enjoyed complete power in
washington for for a year now for two
years now that uh
as they watch this unfold and they watch
the disasters that they have created and
even they realize that that they're
their fault and that the american people
are going to blame them for it in the
election it's going to be pretty scary
between now and november i think now
over at um
mess nbc today molly donnie deutsch
who's
supposedly a big branding genius um he
kind of said the quiet part out loud
about what the democrats strategy is
going to be
we don't have the economy on our side as
democrats so you have to scare the
bejesus out of people the way to scare
that and say you know this replacement
theory this is not just coming from some
dark corner of the web this is the
republican platform make them own it
molly the democrats
have zero to run on they're admitting we
have to go to these
these bizarre theories that no you know
no serious person
out there campaigning for office is
espousing they want a secure border and
a strong economy big deal that's what
most people want
well and it's democrats who keep on
saying that they're going to replace
republican voters with other voters but
it's actually really stupid that they
thought that you know demographic change
would harm the republican party right
now the republican party is a
multi-racial working-class party it has
made tremendous gains in recent years
with a wide variety of americans of
different ethnicities and economic
classes because it's creating policies
that are appealing to those people
what we saw in the last five or six
years with an embrace of protecting the
border of caring about middle-class
workers of taking on global threats to
the country of not doing these
never-ending wars without a clear
entrance or exit strategy that appeals
to a broad multi-racial group of people
and so for them to run this thing right
now is the worst possible moment that
they could be doing it that's a great
point the hispanic vote is again
exploding for the gop and registrations
are up across the board and charlie
i should say that there is a lot more
from what we're calling biden's 48 hours
of hell okay that we didn't have time to
get to oh yeah the pathetic use of the
buffalo tragedy to smear tens of
millions of americans and of course late
today
the city's mayor again they're reeling
from pain and suffering there but he did
make some astonishing remarks
uh hate speech on social media and
radicalizing uh people on social media
has to end certainly that played a large
part in this massacre that occurred in
buffalo new york this past saturday
rhetoric that is inciting violence
is already we know that's not protected
by the first amendment charlie but he
had actually gone on uh in those
comments to say
that it should have there should be no
person who espouses that basically
online now the problem is how would that
work exactly what what is hate speech to
one person may not be hate speech to
another as we can see from these
protests in the streets
yeah well you know it's so despicable
and and think about what kind of
monsters take a horrible tragedy like
this a personal tragedy that breaks
everybody's hearts takes a tragedy like
this and uses it to advance some weird
political agenda that they've got going
you've got to be really really
uh messed up in the head to to to see an
opportunity see this as an opportunity
to do that kind of thing but look at
their two biggest agenda items race uh
playing race politics and global warming
which are both these fear-mongering uh
really disgusting tactics and the reason
they do that the reason democrats resort
to that is because they have no hope of
actually fixing any of the real problems
that affect people's lives and in fact
they've made them worse and and those
things are a distraction from it and
going back to molly's great point about
about the republican party today you
know the reason so many hispanic voters
have come to the republican party is
because they believe in a secure border
too and think about this how racist is
it that you have an entire democrat
party who believes oh you're a hispanic
voter therefore you must love open
borders that's the most racist thing
i've ever heard i know plenty of yeah i
know plenty of hispanic voters they want
a secure border as much as anybody else
you bet well i want to get to this point
about what chuck schumer said today
molly about one particular republican
senator watch
it is repugnant that one member of the
other side the junior senator from
kentucky chose to make a show and
obstruct ukraine funding knowing full
well he couldn't actually stop its
passage
for senator paul to delay ukraine
funding for purely political motives is
to only strengthen putin's hand
molly there's some republicans in
leadership in the senator saying
something
almost
similar to what schumer said there about
rand paul so now everybody has to be for
40 billion dollars going out the window
to ukraine to be a real american is that
what they're saying yeah what senator
paul wanted was if we're going to spend
this money for ukraine which is more
than biden even asked for that there be
just a modicum of accountability for how
it's spent this is a tremendous amount
of money um and this is not the first
tens of billions that we've sent to
ukraine it is presumable that people who
are pushing for an expansion of the war
there will be asking for even more funds
to come and nobody's even debating how
it's going to be spent what
accountability there will be what is the
strategy for how this money is to be
used and whether it's in ukraine's best
interest or this country's best interest
to have this kind of escalation there
molly charlie great to see both of you
thanks so much hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else